and the Wall Street Journal also reports
that Google is allowing third-party
applications to scan the emails of some
Gmail users the Journal says Google does
little to police developers that gain
access to inboxes by offering email
based services such as price comparisons
or other tools Gmail users can sign up
for apps like Ernie unroll me and
boomerang
some companies reportedly have trained
computers or actual employees to scan
inboxes all this is raising concerns
about Gmail security and privacy google
says it vets all the apps that request
access to Gmail accounts and only grants
access with the explicit consent of
users CBS News contributor Nicholas
Thompson is editor-in-chief of Wired
Nick good morning is this similar or the
same to what happened at Facebook with
the Cambridge analytic information it is
similar but less bad in two ways first
with Facebook and Cambridge analytic it
was not only getting access to your info
but the info of your friends and then
secondly we knew that the data had been
misappropriated with Google we just know
that these apps have access to your
inbox we don't know whether they've done
things like sell it to political
campaigns trying to change our elections
nearly two-thirds of active email users
have a Google a gmail account I know you
know it's one and a half billion people
yeah so what's happening here so if I
type in hey honey I'm interested in a
vacation in Italy at a nice hotel and
then all of a sudden an ad pops up for
hotels in Italy
who's scanning my emails well so Google
doesn't do that anymore Gmail initially
would scan your emails and offer you ads
they stopped doing that practice this is
more about if you add an extension you
could have say a price comparison
extension or a travel extension then it
might scan your email and give you
something but you would have to
specifically opt in and install that
extension for them what are these
outside developers able to see well
they're able to see the emails I mean if
you if you get an extension that lets
you organize your emails they're gonna
see your emails if you get an extension
that lets you unroll from newsletters
they're gonna have to see the headers
and information on your emails what's
interesting is that people opt into this
and they do it and they don't quite
understand
reason they don't quite understand is
because the privacy settings were kind
of made in the 2000 the 2017 world
google should have changed I'm not sure
I understand so explain what do you have
you for tenders where do you protect
yourself for opting into yeah okay so if
you install an extension into Google
there into Gmail there will be something
that pops up that says allow
such-and-such app to read and manage
your emails you know you have to click
yes but lots of people do that because
they're not sure so if you want to check
you go to my account google.com and you
go on you see what apps have access to
my inbox and there may be some that you
really like having yeah you don't mind
that they read your Gmail because they
make your Gmail better it's good that
some apps have this what you don't want
is you don't want to have allowed apps
to read your Gmail without them being
useful without you explicitly having
allowed them so is there something
Google should be doing that they're not
doing did they have some explaining to
do here because don't you have to have
access to stuff to make the app better
yeah so it's good that these things
exist Google shouldn't shut this down
they make Gmail better but they should
do two things differently they should be
much more explicit when you sign up
it should say hey this thing's gonna
read your email you sure you want that
you just clicks you wanted that you're
really sure okay totally sure right you
need to change the privacy to do all of
that much clearer uh-huh and then
secondly they need to have restrictions
on what the apps can do with the data
well you don't want it you don't want an
app that you use to organize your inbox
more efficiently which then sells your
data to marketers or then sells it to
hedge funds for investment decisions so
Google probably needs to clear up both
of those things and you we protect
ourselves how you go to my account
Google com you go in and you check and
you see if there's anything that looks
fishy okay and you do that right now if
you haven't done that for a while okay
you have kind of fun actually have a
Google Gmail no I didn't think so I
don't have that emails like what's your
messaging other people
thank you very much